celui dont tu avais pas 28 rentrée mais
là où cette fin trois personnes
condamnées à rester ensemble pour
l'éternité voilà une vision de l'enfer
selon jean paul sartre garcin nerveux et
agressif
inès impoli et arrogante et estelle
bourgeoise superficielle vont devoir se
supporter imes estelle et garcin et le
garçon nous sommes tous les trois morts
nous arriverons d'enfer très vite ils
vont bien voir qu'il ne se supportent
pas mais il va bien falloir quand même
faire avec et ils ont tous fait quelque
chose de répréhensible prédit cependant
faire mais quoi
il va falloir l'avouer ce triangle
infernal en fait monter depuis avril
2016 l'adaptation de scrap en scène se
veut plus légère que le côté dramatique
de la pièce
les quatre comédiens ont opté pour une
mise en scène tournée vers la comédie
je pensais qu'on pouvait elle est et
adaptable en fait elle est modulable
stark à parle de bronze de barbedienne à
brosses barbedienne c'est une statue
très hâte de l'est de l'époque très très
pompeux très fallait d'ailleurs et nous
on l'a remplacé par un âne jardin et du
coup c'est là qu'on est cons ces dix là
on va partir sur un décor très épuré
mais un décor de salon de jardin écrit
en 1943 le message du huis clos reste le
même
encore en 2017 avec cette célèbre phrase
qui résume la pièce l'enfer c'est les
autres
c'est de se questionner c'est pourquoi
on est ici c'est finalement quelles sont
nos actes sur terre le public était avec
nous parce que florent il fait le garçon
il vient nous chercher dans le public
avant avant qu'on commence au début il
va nous chercher il accompagne le public
s'asseoir peut-être que le public
pourrait aussi être être pris pour venir
il est avec il est mort aussi des
interrogations intemporel et universel à
retrouver au théâtre de la croisée des
chemins jusqu'au 18 février
tout à fait tranquille à petit et moi je
ferai en sorte de pas voulu